نائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني فلاديمير
جابري لوف ان لدى بلاده القدره على مهاجمه
السفن الروسيه التي تمر عبر البحر الاسود
في اتجاه موانئ الاتحاد الروسي والموانئ
الاوكرانيه المحتله حسب تعبير
يونس
هل لدينا القدرات اللازمه لمهاجمه السفن
الروسيه مقارنه بالطريقه التي بدات بها
الحرب فنحن الان نمتلك مثل هذه الفرصه
وستكون اكبر وستسمح لنا هذه الفرص بتحقيق
الطموح الذي تحدثنا عنه العام الماضي
ليتحرك اسطول البحر الاسود باكمله بالقرب
من توابسي ونوفورسيسك سنضيق قدره
التحركاتهم حتى في منطقه القرم قدرات
اوكرانيا لا تقتصر على انظمه صواريخ نبتون
فقط توجد انظمه اخرى في الخدمه مع الجيش
الاوكراني اوكرانيا اصبحت الان اقوى بكثير
في هذا الصدد مقارنه بالعام الماضي